o si bienvenidas a la entrevista de
france 24 hoy nos acompaña el colectivo
feminista chileno de valparaíso las
tesis ella se hicieron conocidas
mundialmente con su performance un
violador en tu camino que coincidió
además con todo el estallido social que
se produjo en chile y que hoy cumple dos
años saludamos entonces a paula duff de
sidi la idea que tal como están hola muy
bien
quien comienza explicando nos cuál es el
objetivo de esta visita a francia y en
general una gira europea que están
haciendo
bueno
difundir en
nuestros trabajos que se basan en
teorías feministas
nos han invitado a distintos tipos de
instancias conversatorios
performance y también talleres en donde
hemos podido trabajar con las mujeres y
personas de las disidencias
de lisboa y también en los suns en suiza
y en general es poder trabajar en estos
territorios
en la resistencia de quién es
se encuentran acá poder generar redes y
construir lazos
intercontinentales sin fronteras porque
las problemáticas son las mismas en todo
lado en general si hay cosas
del patriarcado que son transversales
ya que también está muy presente el tema
de la migración como la lucha inmigrante
igual que nuestro país entonces hay
varios puntos comunes de nuestros
trabajos que hemos encontrado y ha sido
el raterismo me imagino que este su
primer gran viaje después de la pandemia
la pandemia paralizó un poco lo que fue
la revuelta social en chile y me imagino
que también lo que fue toda esta
exclusión feminista que nació justamente
a partir de vuestra performance porque
además las mujeres fueron grandes
protagonistas de la revuelta social en
chile una de las líderes de la revuelta
social con los estudiantes secundarios
como les ha afectado que han hecho en
todo este tiempo ustedes como este esta
fama internacional que consiguieron
luego
qué pasó con ella después de la durante
la pandemia que en chile todavía sigue
muy presente también con muchas
restricciones todavía con movimientos
feministas como el movimiento social en
general en chile no creemos que se hayan
apagado de ninguna manera sino más bien
empezó a operar y activar de otras
maneras y a partir de otras estrategias
dentro de lo que la pandemia permitía
porque un supuesto teníamos que
cuidarnos contra este virus el ímpetu
está ahí está aún muy se siente muy
fuerte bueno lo vimos también lo que
estuvo pasando este 18 de octubre acaba
de suceder en chile o sea claramente eso
está lejos de terminar y por otro lado
nosotros en particular hemos siguió
activando desde las artes que lo que
nosotras hacemos este activismo
artístico a través de todas las
plataformas que podemos utilizar en ese
sentido rápidamente también intentamos
adaptarnos a los formatos digitales
nosotros creemos muchísimo en el tweet
yourself hágalo usted misma a mí mismo
y en ese sentido no importa que no
tuviéramos mayores herramientas ni de
edición de sonido vídeos y teníamos que
transformar un poco lo que hacíamos
hacia la videoperformance por ejemplo lo
íbamos a hacer igual que lo que
empezamos a hacer un poco utilizar todas
las plataformas y formatos que podamos
seguir utilizando de algo que vamos a
con lo cual vamos a insistir porque
finalmente nuestra lucha está con el
movimiento feminista latinoamericano y
desde que nosotros tenemos este pequeño
espacio de enunciación debido a la
visibilidad que tuvo nuestro trabajo es
algo que vamos a seguir explotando de
todas las maneras posibles
tenemos que una responsabilidad con el
movimiento feminista de hecho una de las
cosas que hicieron cierto fue publicar
vuestro manifiesto escrito desde la
rabia quién me puede comentar y para
nuestro público cuál han sido las
principales conclusiones enunciados
ideas de este texto que van trabajando
siete enunciados que son siete temas que
también hemos trabajado dentro de
nuestras escenas temas que tienen que
ver con el trabajo doméstico con el
aborto
con la violencia estatal
y finalmente termina con
una subida de ánimo el libro porque te
deja como en
la capacidad transformadora de la
performance en ese libro tienen la
capacidad de que más que está escrito
desde la rabia claramente pero es un
libro que apela a transformar la rabia
en creación el hecho de que se hayan
vuelto tan conocidas no porque vimos la
curación en el mundo entero incluso aquí
en la torre eiffel y todo eso tuvo cosas
positivas el hecho de que el general en
varios países se plegaron al movimiento
y negativas como la denuncia que le hizo
la policía chilena que finalmente
ustedes salieron absueltas cómo evalúan
eso que vivieron
es violencia institucional si es dura se
asegura de la manera más burda y ordena
bien
ha sido complejo para nosotras porque la
persecución ha sido constante por un
lado está la persecución en redes
sociales digitales está la persecución
por parte también de políticos en toda
la política institucional que están
pendientes de lo que nosotros hacemos de
re compartir y atacarnos por twitter
etcétera sobre todo gente de extrema
derecha aunque enemigos los feminismos
tienen en todas partes sabemos pero el
caso el caso de carabineros como el más
emblemático quizás porque un poco
sintetiza esta violencia institucional
al ocupar además su poder como
institución que posee el monopolio de la
violencia pero que además toman cientos
etc
e instrumentaliza en el sistema judicial
para perseguirnos y además filtra en
esta información a la prensa a los
medios de comunicación que en este caso
es un medio de comunicación en
particular que un poco está ahí al
servicio de perseguir a ya sea la gente
que se está vinculando a la política
como también artistas en este caso a
nosotras que filtra esta información
para que nosotras nos enterara concierto
y en un contexto en el cual estaban
restringidas también las libertades
debido a la pandemia en un contexto en
el cual para poder salir a la calle tú
tenías que pedir un permiso a la misma
institución y que si alguien te paraba
en la calle podía ser de esa misma
institución eso evidentemente el nivel
de violencia concreta pero también
simbólica que tiene es muy fuerte y se
tradujo en que para nosotras
también es que tratamos de que no sea
así pero es un momento igual empezó a
limitar nuestro trabajo en el hecho de
cómo hacer qué estrategias emplear para
que no les instrumentalice luego en
nuestra contra entonces esté cuidado con
el lenguaje con las palabras porque
nosotros trabajamos son artistas
trabajamos la metáfora y el hecho de que
estas personas lo toman desde la
literalidad para por ejemplo de
mandarnos denunciarnos y que no era una
las dos denuncias también nos multaron a
raíz de una convocatoria que hicimos
para hacer una performance en el espacio
público previo a plebiscito con muy
terrible para nosotras llegar al punto
al que habíamos convocado y que por un
lado estuviera la policía esperándonos y
que luego cuando es que realizamos esta
performance que estaba muy organizada
para que fuera comida amigable por
porque creemos en que tenemos que
cuidarnos etcétera sin embargo abajo no
estuvieron en el plan esperando con
militares armamentos y luego bueno nos
multan y eso se tradujo en que mientras
estuviera el estado decepción en chile
nosotros no podíamos volver a convocar
nada porque si no éramos reincidentes
dentro de estas leyes su vida etcétera
la ley de sanitaria y por ende
llegábamos prisión cárcel
es así es así están constantemente
encima de nosotras vigilan nuestras
casas con dron todos los días hay drones
sobrevolando nuestras casas o sea eso
sucede hoy allá en valparaíso entonces
evidentemente como artista y activista
es complejo vivir de esa manera sin
embargo queremos y nos hemos apoyado en
ese sentido del colectivo en los otros
cuatro pero también en este colectivo
más amplio de todas las personas que nos
apoyan en nuestro trabajo para seguir
creando y seguir activando y no dejar
que estas personas no vuelvan a
silenciar pero yo creo que también una
de las cosas más terribles es que en ese
tiempo que nos demandaron en chile la
gente estaba muriendo de hambre de frío
se estaban convocando ellas comunes la
pobreza se acrecentó se mostró tal como
era ese encuentro de que el nivel de
vulgaridad y de enajenación de la
realidad de la de la policía chilena es
algo que es terrorífico y que de verdad
en esta construcción de la nueva
sociedad deberíamos abolir la policía y
hablando de la construcción de la nueva
sociedad el mundo entero ha mirado a
chile y eso quizás es algo positivo de
el movimiento feminista
comisión constituyente paritaria primero
como lo evalúan ustedes es una conquista
el movimiento feminista de la revuelta
social es suficiente es una
una solución aún
problema muy profundo
pero no era lo que se demandaba
entonces
está bien que exista un organismo
paralelo al congreso y nuestros poderes
pero lo que se resuelva y de igual
manera va a tener que ser votado
y si lo que está en discusión
llega a buen puerto y es rechazado
volvemos a este círculo vicioso del
pasado en el presente entonces es muy
complejo porque además la clase política
en chile
están muy desprestigiadas y los nuevos
políticos no se han aparecido también
han tenido malas prácticas entonces hay
un vicio dentro de todos estos sistemas
de poder entonces
está bien que esté pero siempre hay que
estar un poco observando las las
dinámicas que finalmente pueden resultar
un poco
iniciadas y la campaña del terror en
chile en contra de la convención
constituyente por parte de la política
institucional fascista de los partidos
de derecha y por parte de la prensa
fascista también que como decía antes
siempre se presta se presta para esto y
otras conquistas le quedan pendiente al
feminismo chileno entonces muchas muchas
muchas hay muchas cosas pendientes
de educación sexual integral el aborto
es una gran lucha que estamos llevando
adelante
infinitas infinitas el derecho a la vida
a la tierra
a una vida libre de violencia
usted todas las de los medios de
comunicación es una impedido que ustedes
hagan una campaña con netflix la
plataforma de videos
porque tiene una serie que son educación
sexual y vuestra performance es
utilizada con un vídeo muy creativo y
muy animado
cómo nació esa colaboración y por qué el
aceptar primero acotar que la prensa
fascista no es lo mismo que una
plataforma como la primera
y luego otro es que nosotros tenemos un
poco esta idea de también a su vez
instrumentalizar las plataformas de
anunciación que tengamos en ese sentido
netflix es una plataforma muy amplia que
llega a muchas personas y ahí el
discurso tiene que ver en contenidos
tiene que ver con la lucha contra la
violencia sexual entonces para nosotros
tenía mucho sentido lo mismo que los
libros en el aire los publicados con
grandes editoriales porque lo podríamos
haber hecho con editoriales
independientes por supuesto pero nuestro
objetivo llegar a la mayor cantidad de
gente posible evidentemente si nunca
comprometer nuestras ideas como en
nuestro país no existe una ley de
educación integral mucha información que
los jóvenes obtienen respecto a ese tema
a través de estos contenidos
entonces para nosotras era importante
igual participar de esa manera y ser un
aporte
a esta plataforma o a estas personas que
están trabajando por él porque esa
información sea más democrática y no así
no sean nuestros gobiernos nuestros
políticos que rechazan que eso se haga
en la escuela donde corresponde hacerlo
finalmente usted es bueno en su libro es
manifiesto la antología y en lo que son
sus acciones críticas siempre no ser
todo el patriarcado cuál es la opción
alternativa que proponen yo creo que el
patriarcado fuera que nos cruza todo es
un trabajo que cada ser humano
introspectivamente tiene que hacer para
comprender cómo erradicar lo de su
funcionamiento entonces el que nosotros
creamos una propuesta es como seguir
simplificando la labor a todos los seres
humanos que deberían hacer la labor
propia probablemente estamos más en el
plano de la denuncia de la denuncia y de
visibilización de las problemáticas
ese otro proceso de ok cómo se va a
hacer es complejo no sé si nos
corresponde si hay ciertas luces
evidentemente
partiendo de la base de que todas las
personas tenemos los mismos derechos
independiente de nuestro género de
nuestra expresión
de género sexual no pueden haber
diferencia por nuestra color etcétera
como que yo creo que partiendo de ahí
muchas gracias entonces sí vi la lía
paula y darle son las tesis de chile
muchas gracias por habernos acompañado y
ustedes sigan con la programación
habitual de france 24
[Música]